promixité vous est présenté par ngj
acteur engagé en faveur de l'égalité
[Musique]
professionnelle bonjour à tous et
bienvenue dans promixité l'émission qui
vous parle de la place des femmes dans
le monde du travail aujourd'hui focus
sur les métiers de la tech où les femmes
sont toujours sous représentées c'est ce
que dénonce un nouveau rapport du Haut
Conseil à l'égalité d'ailleurs les
chiffres de l'INC parlent de même elles
ne sont que 30 % à occuper un poste dans
le numérique dont 16 % dans les métiers
techniques et 22 % dans les postes de
direction une sous-représentation du
selon le HCE à un manque de modèle
féminin auquel s'identifier mais aussi à
une peur du sexisme qui sévit dans ce
secteur et également à un frein à
l'orientation par l'entourage résultats
ne sont que 7 % des adolescentes à
souhaité s'orienter dans les métiers du
NUM contre 29 % pour les garçons et
infin elle ne représente que 17 % des
diplômés exerçants dans ce secteur alors
pour casser ce cercle vicieux le HCE
préconise des quotas dans les filières
du numérique y compris au lycée voilà pr
cité c'est fini pour aujourd'hui on se
retrouve très vite sur public
scenna
promicité vous a été présenté par ngj
acteur engagé en faveur de l'égalité
professionnelle